have you heard about Detroit Michigan it
is going to hell in a handbasket we have
talked about this a little bit before
but but Detroit is literally cutting off
water to its residents who can't afford
to pay their water bills and now I know
some people that well you can't afford
water that is you're gonna have water
really okay yeah that's right nearly
300,000 people may soon have their water
turned off some people have had the
water turned off already
15,000 have had their water shut down
and the water company is not slowing but
PETA which is People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals they want to lend a
hand
by agreeing to pay the late water bills
for 10 Detroit families and what's the
catch well you just have to eat vegan
yeah that's right we've got a quote from
the PETA blog the last thing that people
who are struggling need is increased
health care cost by accepting our offer
to go vegan not only will families be
getting an immediate financial boost and
helping animals if they stick with it
they'll also lower their risk of obesity
heart disease cancer diabetes and
strokes okay so they're trying to do
something nice now this is only 10
they're only doing this for 10 families
now there are literally thousands and
thousands of people that are having
their water 10 but I guess they're
trying to do something nice here but by
the nature of this being 10 families
isn't it fair to say this is far more of
a publicity stunt than actual work to
get these people to have their water
back on that doesn't sound like the PETA
I know that they would be oh yes I mean
of course the publicity stunt but
realistically and I don't know if
anybody's even going to take them up on
it it seems like one of the challenge I
mean it's hard enough to get like if you
live in a inner city of Detroit
those are food we're called food deserts
and it's hard enough to learn about
grocery stores and something that they
have to shop at bodegas until I can I
don't I haven't been to Detroit so I
don't know what Detroit is like
specifically one vegan basket to get
them started welcome and like where are
they gonna where they're gonna eat this
vegan but uh realistically is a big
glass of water to choke down that tofu
it could be very drunk I'm not gonna
badmouth vegan
because your we have there there are
people in this part of this network who
are you very unhappy with yeah and but
yes it's publicity son for PETA but
realistically it's also a publicity
stunt to draw attention to the fact of
what's going on in Detroit with these
people if not for PETA we wouldn't be
talking about this probably so while you
can accuse them of you know using
whatever tactics they can take and banjo
hopping on the Detroit water bandwagon
at least we're talking about it and it's
raising awareness about that issue and I
think we should also recognize that the
residents of Detroit while they are
having their water cut off the
businesses of Detroit are not having
their water cut off even though they are
they owe Detroit the sea of Detroit like
or the water company five million
dollars or more and they do not face
because they can they can fight it
legally but poor people have no capacity
to fight this legally so they're the
ones who get screwed over so that being
said should we cut Peter some slack here
it seems like kind of just a publicity
stuff but there I think this is
deplorable
I think this is so demeaning this is a
way of I mean III think I think a lot of
us think that water is a basic human
right you've got to have water you can
survive for a while without eating I
can't but you can survive way less we're
first of all countries I always forget
my notes here yeah and that's the thing
I I get Peter's vibe I support a lot of
things they do I'm happy for the most
part that they exist but I think this is
so degrading to the people of Detroit to
say will help you with your water bill
which for an organization like PETA
isn't a lot of money if you you know
dance clown dance like do what we want
you to do and try and eat vegan like
[ __ ] you it's not about you and your
agenda it's about these people not
having water I think it's I think it's
it's humiliating to the people who take
them up on it and I think they're
totally demeaning and degrading the
people of Detroit you know what I was
sorta in between the two you but by the
time you finish that sentence I'm with
you and it reminds me of these people
like in New York City when there are
homeless people asking for money and I
had a friend who would be walking a
comic that I used to know and we'd be
walking down a street in times where
maybe all these homeless people and he'd
be like I only give homeless people that
if they do something like I want them to
do something you know what I mean like
sing a song or do a card trick
something like that but because then
they're doing something otherwise I'm
just giving them something and I think
that that goes your point what are you
saying the fact that we're just watching
a city in our country literally fall
apart now I have been to Detroit and
there are parts of Detroit that are
really nice the the baseball stadium is
really nice the publicly funded GM
Renaissance Center which is where the
original Total Recall is from really
nice it's great it's really cool so
there's some stuff but if you go outside
of that I mean it almost looks like a
war zone there are houses just decimated
there are areas that are completely gone
we're watching this happen in America
it's never on the knees yeah the city of
Detroit is disintegrating and it's this
I mean it relates to the other topic we
did with the income inequality and the
collapse of the middle class in America
collapse of unions I mean there's you
know the but it's it didn't just happen
I know there are people who say oh that
they blame the residents of Detroit it
didn't just happen these four policies
that were pursued and this is the
logical outcome of those policies and
there are certain people who gain from
this and there are others who don't and
the people who gain from it have all the
political influence on people who don't
do not and I also think that there are
gimmicks there are like these weird
little kind of dare I use this word fun
ways to get attention on Detroit I know
that a while ago they were auctioning
off houses for like next to nothing
beautiful houses live here come put
money back into the community that's
awesome that's an amazing publicity
stunt and I hope it worked but this this
is adding insult to injury because
either we're not talking about how the
city has been destroyed when this city
was the backbone of how America was
America I mean like people you know
people talk about well you know my
grandfather worked for GM for many years
and you know he had a great retirement
house and we had a you know all this
stuff
they have nothing now and then to add
insult to injury saying if if you if you
tell us a joke or juggle we'll give you
you know 100 bucks for your water it's
horrible it used to be there's been a
great advances in the quality of vegan
food by the way also I was a vegetarian
for 13 years I regret every day of it I
think that's a perfect